um
you recently got shot yeah
are you I mean you're fine you're here
I'm good
um but uh
I mean that has to be a traumatic thing
to to get through
it wasn't really like traumatic to me
though like did you I mean I don't want
you to get into the specifics of the
situation but like
is that something that happens and do
you become like a different person after
that or do you move differently after
something like that happens it changed
me but it ain't it ain't it changed me
for the better like
um
I know what I'd be doing when I get into
stuff so I know what be going on like I
know the possibility to shoot that that
come behind my actions and even my
reaction so
but I wouldn't say like I got shot
I damn sure wouldn't do nothing
different so it ain't changed me on the
situation so I just changed me to move
better for real well I feel like too
like uh at a lot of the younger artists
that I speak with man you're like one of
the more like you're a very smart kid
man like when I interviewed you
um with Sada baby I felt like you were
the adult in the interview
and me and Sarah baby were like the uh
the old creepy uncles and you're like I
don't do drugs y'all are talking about
gas station dick pills what the [ __ ] are
y'all dudes on but like in terms of just
like your attitude I was like yo like
you really got
the type of attitude that will like
result in longevity as long as you could
just try to stay out the way of that
other [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
I really don't I don't normally get into
stuff like that it just sometimes you're
just at the wrong place at the wrong
time of course you feel me something
you're just inevitable
stuff is like unavoidable right yeah
like you can't uh you can't be like
cooped up in the [ __ ] house all day
for sure like stuff just like happening
lightning strikes places yeah like
that's why like you can't
you got like you got to be strong-minded
about stuff like you gotta know like
accept what come with what you're doing
right
what's uh was just a feeling like like
was it the craziest pain you've ever
been through in terms of just physical
right I ain't feel when I got shot I
ain't even full
all right yeah and that's I walked off
if you didn't feel it I saw adrenaline's
pumping I'm sure
I don't know I just walked off and [ __ ]
that just happened like I ain't it ain't
the shortness after getting shot is
really what hurt like right like the
after effects are like recovering and
like the big ass Bros I had on my ass
because it went through my stomach and
came on my ass don't nobody even know
that so the Bullet came out of your butt
cheek I swear to God
laughs
did you have to sit on a donut
no not for real I broke my tailbone not
the same thing when I was like it's 50
went straight through I ain't hitting no
bones or hitting us so just straight
booty meat so you're okay
that had to be a rough go for like
taking a [ __ ] for a few months huh
like you put all the [ __ ] weight on
them like the cheek that didn't get shot
I mean I mean it couldn't have been the
most comfortable thing it wasn't
comfortable it was a big ass bruise on
my [ __ ] like you ever feel like you
played Sports and like feel on hardwood
yeah oh yeah it felt like that like but
I was laughing and [ __ ] my mama was mad
because I got out the hospital the same
night it was laughing and [ __ ] I played
I played too much for real okay you got
a lot of talent man you got a lot of uh
you got a bright future ahead of you bro
you gotta just you know try to avoid all
that all those situations I'm a real
manner young man though I want people to
really know that I agree I'm a real
manner I don't look for trouble I'm not
going to get in trouble none of that I'm
I'm a good person